انتشر مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ظهر فيه الدكتور علي جمعه مفتي
الديار المصريه الاسبق وهو يوبخ طلبه
انفصل انصرفوا عن درسه الى درس شيخ اخر
وسريعا انتقل الحدث الى مواقع التواصل
فانقسم روادها بين مؤيد للدكتور ومنتقد
حيث وصفوا ما قام به الطلبه بقله الاحترام
واخرون برروا بان الطلبه كانوا ملتزمين
بدرس اخر نتابع
[موسيقى]
من استطاع منكم ان ينفع اخاه بشيء فليفعل
والان لا مديه ايه دول سلفيه دول ولا
مش راضيين حاجه انتم قائمين ايه ده انت
وهو رايحين فين ايه الشيخ مصطفى الازهري
مين مين الشيخ مصطفى الازهري
مصطفى رضا
ويقول لك اهو بعض الازهريه
هنا في البتاعه واسمع الدرس لغايه الاخر
مشاهد متداوله على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي للفيضانات عارمه اجتاحت مدن
العراقيه بعد هطول امطار غزيره غير مسبوقه
اغرقت الشوارع ودفعت الحكومه الى اعلان
التعطيل للدوام الرسمي والمدارس نشاهد
حادث سير وكانه من مشهد فيلم اكشن تداول
رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو
لحادث سير الماساوي نتيجه انفصال عجله
سياره مسرعه على الطريق السريع في
كاليفورنيا الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
بقع بيضاء قد تتسبب في اعدام حارس زعيم
كوريا الشماليه الازمه بدات عندما ظهر كم
خلال اطلاق صاروخ عابر للقارات لكن الملفت
هو تواجد بقع غامضه على ملابسه اذ يعتقد
ان الزعيم كم لامس سبب بملابسه طلاء ابيض
لكن يخشى ان يتسبب الامر في عقاب حارسه
حيث يصل الامر الى الاشغال الشاقه او حتى
الاعدام وفق ما ذكره مايكل مازن خبير شؤون
النخبه في كوريا الشماليه وفي مثل هذه
المواقف يتوقف الامر على الحاله المزاجيه
للزعيم
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء